[Musique]
retrouvez allons nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission où sonne ça
découvre la réunion ensemble vous allez
parler alors à l'eau
sa mère parle pas mal et
alors au cinq mille et dans la commune
de saint-joseph plus précisément à 4
blanc est de nous ça découvre la pêche à
la truite par les allées allons-nous com
- ses enfants rien que ça mais mon
élément
si l'on retrouve mon moment
rien que la même au cannet
[Musique]
comme si la nature ne connaît à l'apa il
nous reste à
côté ben voilà non plus toujours sur le
sentier de câbles on est au bout de 20
minutes de marche au telegraph que ça
nous voir ici nous appellent à la basse
à la corbeille ou s'ils n'auraient pas
les larges que danone lâche ici en tout
cas les vraiment jolie donc et vidéo que
la saison en six courses à joseph
l'appela vraiment bien tomber et la
remplit le magnifique bassin
alors dans la montée on a une petite
famille d'un groupe là il fait une pause
baugeois ans je voyais bonjour madame
salue les enfants ça va abalo
bonjour comme moi y est elle est là et
la témoin d'un oiseau non regroupées au
sol ça va comme ça leur sac à dos de
routine ou là en famille et celle ci
d'authie ça va souvent mais alors
découvrons
amicone mai manif et des comas belle
famille à cause de ces pannes habib sy
non tampon d'accord les récentes hausses
allaient mois et est ce que sinon une
randonnée les facile oui
si l'on l'a dit richard guay la pêche
est ce que tu connais que seguer pêcher
sur ou serna tombés d'accord bain ou
pêche wimy pêche ils ont donc salon
est-ce que c'est andrew ladd jeunes du
péché oui manhattan y pêcher mais par
contre mais la bande truites mais il
faut bien regarder le la grandeur à
pascal annen wind réglementation par
contre d'accord mais c'est au tour du
gabon mais ça monte ça lui allait baba à
l'émail
ôtez ben voilà après une heure de marche
depuis parking nous on arrive ici à 4
blanc 700 mètres d'altitude pourquoi pas
les caps blancs il paraît que seule la
partie haute de câbles en maintenant à
tout un espace où nana des lichens tout
blanc la recouvre l'espace en tout cas
nous n'a de l'année rodez comme l'espace
à pêcher la truite et ben maxwell arrivé
à eybens balewa sa mémoire à madame avec
un cahier un paquet bonjour madame
bonjour moi les bains savait où voulait
bien oui dia - tout sauf un petit peu
utiles à la monnaie ou en train de
prendre des notes à manu voir le spectre
8 est ce que donne à beaucoup de vent a
été détruite à la réunion n'a une seule
variété de truites c'est la truite arc
en ciel et comme on est riche en eau du
goût ben en gros dans les années 1940
pour un petit peu pallier au manque de
nourriture dans les eaux banal a
introduit la truite dans les rivières
pour que bones habitants et manger il
faut un permis spécial pas pardon -
migani la pêche et la wii il faut avoir
un permis de pêche pour pêcher et aussi
le nan période aussi qu'on doit
respecter en ce moment par exemple on
peut pas pêcher en 1re catégorie la
nouille en première catégorie mais ont
pêché en deuxième catégorie alors tous à
la cession des roubaisiens en eau alors
2 octobre à met donc au mois d'octobre à
partir du mois d'octobre va gagner a
pêché un thème la gaillarde
alors du coup nous la quittons la
rivière et ça allait bien ce par quoi là
si nous venions vie continue et par an
dont ils ont envie d'aller à la plaine
des sables ou bien au volcan nous ça va
pas là et moi ça me sera fait mais ça
profite de l'occasion pour aller faire
un petit tour dans la forêt vont un
petit peu que ça dans la com' plantes
éventuellement y en a et messieurs
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment ai je
le donnais pas l'or a pas vraiment un
pas intéressant mais pas tout à fait
d'accord d'accord en fait la ou les sur
une parcelle de restauration écologique
à coup ses visions sont donc en fait
avec l'association agréée de pêche c'est
une zone sur laquelle on va éliminer des
espèces exotiques envahissantes
quand vous remettre en valeur des
espèces indigènes et endémiques le fait
de dégager aussi la parcelle d'éliminer
tout c'est exotique que vous voyez sur
le côté qui vont vraiment tout étouffer
là on a un tapis de longues aux le fait
de les arracher sa a faire un apport de
lumière et ça va permettre aux semences
qui sont dans le sol de se régénérer
naturellement d'accord ok tu es bon en
tout cas les chouettes et comme espèce
endémique au sein de guerre ont trouvé
alors du coup le jeune et n'a dû
ici du bois de nèfles notamment alors
qu'il est à bois de nèfles à petites
feuilles manu changer corse encore
derrière moi là bas qu'on appelle aussi
goyave marron ok c'est donc changé corse
qu'on voit que son écorce au fur et à
mesure de sa croissance se décolle pour
laisser place à une nouvelle peau une
nouvelle écosse justement d'où son
appellation de changer corse vraiment
tout un panel d'espèces l'aduf leurs
jeunes du de l'emba ville duffy guerrouj
dubois mecque du bois d'auch ce taux il
ya vraiment des dizaines et des dizaines
d'espèces qu'on a régénéré sur cette
parcelle en tout cas les gagnants les
coaches une balade en bas on a trouvé
ben bonne malades mais aussi allez bye
c'est bon en tout cas ben elle est
vraiment intéressant et bien du coup ça
vit ça a fait c'est que moi mais ça à
voir si vous gagnez trouve un pêcheur
aller
mon pays commande
la réunion ça mène
ap lé respect pour mon pays vraiment
après des pissenlits
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment allez
vous elle va très bien merci alors dites
moi qu'est ce que vous faites
actuellement je suis en train de pêcher
la truite arc en ciel dans la partie
vocale de là fédération et je pêche aux
coques là c'est à dire en vers de terre
d'accord je remets les poissons à l'eau
après d'accord est-ce que ça fait
longtemps vous pratiquer la pêche oui
depuis depuis l'âge de 10-12 ans
d'accord et d'où vous est venue cette
passion mais ça m'est venue de mes
parents de mes grands parents c'est ces
familles là c'est une passion familiale
ah ouais on perpétue la tradition en
essayant de faire en sorte que les
milieux aquatiques sont respectées c'est
sûr que ça fait pour nous le plus
important problème de l'eau et des
milieux aquatiques c'est devenu un sujet
primordial je crois que avec le
réchauffement climatique ça commence à
devenir sensible extrêmement simple
d'accord mais bon en tout cas merci mais
montgaillard bonne pêche merci à tous
et ben voilà l'action de l'accablant
t'es vraiment gaillard haute et la
reynerie nagaya fait froid à l'on prend
le temps vise italie et poussa rendez
vous approchez l'épisode de l'émission
allô cette fois ci le sera dans la
commune de saint benoît il valait
découvre la forêt c'est ma de riz aux
télés gagnaire semaine la troupe
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présentée par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]